often our partner isn't necessarily
being terrible in any overt way but we
feel a growing sadness about the
character of our relationship the
partner isn't as focused on us as we'd
hoped there often times when they don't
understand us properly they're often
busy and preoccupied they can be a bit
off hand or abrupt they're not hugely
interested in the details of our day
they call their friends rather than talk
with us we feel disenchanted and let
down love was supposed to be lovely but
without any one huge thing having gone
wrong
it doesn't feel much that way day to day
this sorrow has a paradoxical sauce
we're upset now because at some point in
the past we were really rather fortunate
with sad because we've been lucky to
explain the seeming paradox we need to
have a look at the intimate origins of
love
our idea of what a good loving
relationship should be like and what it
feels like to be loved doesn't ever come
from what we've seen in adulthood it
arises from a stranger more powerful
source the idea of happy coupledom taps
into a fundamental picture of comfort
deep security wordless communication and
of our needs being effortlessly
understood that comes from early
childhood at the best moments of
childhood if things went reasonably well
a loving parent offered us extraordinary
satisfaction they knew when we were
hungry or tired even though we couldn't
usually explain we didn't need to strive
they made us feel completely safe we
were held peacefully we were entertained
and indulged and even if we don't recall
the explicit details the experience of
being cherished has made a profound
impression on us it's planted itself in
our deep minds as the ideal template of
what love should be as adults without
really noticing we continue to be
enthralled to this notion of being loved
projecting the best experience of our
early years into our present
relationships and finding them sorely
wanting as a result
a comparison that is profoundly
corrosive and unfair the love we
received from a parent can't ever be a
workable model for our later adult
experience of love
the reason is fundamental we were a baby
then we are an adult now a dichotomy
with several key ramifications for a
start our needs were so much simpler
back then we needed to be washed amused
put to bed but we didn't need someone to
trawl intelligently through the troubled
corners of our minds we didn't need a
caregiver to understand why we prefer
the first series of a television show to
the second why it's necessary to see our
aunt on Sunday or why it matters to us
so much of the curtains harmonize with
the sofa covers or that bread must be
cut with a proper bread knife the parent
knew absolutely what was required in
relation to certain basic physical and
emotional requirements our partner on
the other hand is stumbling in the dark
around needs that are immensely subtle
far from obvious and very complicated to
deliver upon secondly none of it was
reciprocal back then the parent was
intensely focused on caring for us but
they knew and totally accepted that we
wouldn't engage with their needs they
didn't for a second imagine that they
could take their troubles to us or
expect us to nurture them they didn't
need us to ask them about that day our
responsibility was blissfully simple all
we had to please them was to exist our
most ordinary actions rolling over on
our tummy grasping a biscuit in our tiny
hand enchanted them with ease we were
loved we didn't have to love a
distinction between kinds of love which
language normally artfully blurs
shielding us from the difference between
being the privileged customer of love or
it's more exhausted and long-suffering
provider furthermore our parents were
probably kind enough to shield us from
the burden that looking after us imposed
on them they maintained a reasonably
sunny facade until they retired to their
own bedroom at which point the true toll
of their efforts could be witnessed but
by then we were asleep they did us the
honor of not
showing us what looking after us custom
which was immensely kind but did us one
lasting disservice it may unwittingly
have created an expectation of what it
could mean for someone to love us which
was never true in the first place we
might in later life end up with lovers
who attach you with us who were too
tired to talk at the end of the day who
don't marvel at our every antic who
can't even be bothered to listen to what
we're saying and we might feel with some
bitterness that this is not how our
parents were the irony which has its
redeeming side is that in truth this is
exactly how our parents were just up in
their bedroom when we were asleep and
realize nothing the source of our
present sorrow is not there for a
special failing on the part of our adult
lovers they are not tragically inept nor
uniquely selfish it's rather that we're
judging our adult experiences in the
light of a very different kind of
childhood love we are sorrowful not
because we've landed with the wrong
person but because we have sadly been
forced to grow up
you